dania was 11 when this photo was taken
at a hospital in aleppo
she'd been hit by shrapnel while playing
near her home it's just one of the
harrowing scenes captured by nicholas
hamstrom a young boy was brought in by
some men
together with some other injured people
the boy was badly burnt and in shock i
started talking to him and
held his
it's
hand
and
very very strong
moment
this is the second year in a row that a
photo from syria has won the award even
though images from the conflict are
relatively scarce that's because very
few journalists are able to gain access
germany's first lady daniela schatt has
just returned from a visit to jordan
where she toured a refugee camp for
syrian children
millions of youngsters have been caught
up in the war many have been left
orphans
we're unable to end the civil war
but we have to ensure that help is
available to these people
and that we don't become desensitized
shot describes the photographs as a
warning to the world not to abandon an
entire generation
dania survived her injuries but she's
still living in aleppo where the war
rages on